so transcribe sentence let's listen to
The First One
let's see oh there's a mistake there
have you been learning a language for
some time and you're frustrated to no
end by how little you can actually
understand when native speakers Converse
at a normal Pace do you wish you could
finally enjoy a movie or a series in
your target language without having to
rely on subtitles the answer to your
problem lies in developing strong
listening comprehension skills
if you can relate to this stay tuned
because by the end of this video your
views on understanding a native speech
will be changed forever I'm here with a
very special guest today who's going to
put me through a little challenge to see
how well I actually understand native
speech in multiple languages and we're
going to show you a tried and tested
Training Method that can help you
improve your ability to understand
native speakers even when they talk fast
I promise it's gonna be fun let's Dive
Right In
hi guys I'm here with hopes who is not
just a good friend of mine but also a
very passionate language learner so I
will let him introduce himself before we
talk about the topic of today
it's all yours hi everyone uh I'm from
Germany I'm not only passionate about
language learning but also about
language education
finding ways to learn languages better
and faster and as you might have guessed
being here with Luca today who speaks
how many language do you speak 14
foreign languages 14 plus mind wow
14. last time I checked was only 12.
well I'll be missing out yeah I have
well I should be following you more
often social media I guess you should
anyway uh we have a really interesting
topic today a topic that I think should
be at the top of the list of every
serious language learner and that is
listening comprehension excellent so
let's talk about listening comprehension
but before we do I want to ask you this
question how do you get into language
learning in general and language
education well that was when I had my
pivotal moment with learning Spanish a
few years ago I just passed the B1 level
exam and I thought okay I'm now finally
at an intermediate level and then a few
days later I was at a restaurant with a
friend and at the next table there were
a few Spanish people having an animated
conversation and although I was
listening to them the whole time I
realized I cannot understand anything or
what he was saying
and at that moment it dawned on me there
must be something wrong with the way
I've been learning the language
I would say to Europe's credit that this
is a very common situation it reminds me
of not only myself and what I had to
endure and go through but also of a
student of mine an American student of
mine she had been learning Spanish for
two years and then she went to Mexico
she had prepared some lines to interact
with waiters at restaurants Etc then she
did say in those lines she managed to
get her point across the problem was
that when the waiter replied she was at
a loss she couldn't understand anything
I still remember as as if it were today
that she said the guy said so before we
talk about the how and I'm pretty sure
that you're very interested in the how
to improve your listening comprehension
let's first address the problem of why
this happens why is it so difficult to
understand native speakers in real life
situations I think there are several
reasons first of all Native speech tends
to be very fast and it's fleeting uh
it's the moment it comes out it's gone
you either understand it or you don't uh
the other aspect that's important is
colloquialisms you may have spent years
studying language from books and courses
and you still cannot understand common
casual phrases that are used every day
by actual native speakers true
um the thing is when it comes to
understanding the real spoken language
the problem is that the language that
native speakers use is very different
from that of course books right
absolutely so for example the French
they say June sepa when you see it in a
nice packaged sentence in a course book
but then what do what do you hear when
people say June
or shipa right accompanied by shrupa
very fast right then you know to be
honest I mean do you always speak in
full phrases when you speak in Italian
do you only use formal language probably
not right so it's not just the French
who speak this way it's also the
Italians the Germans the Spanish Etc so
um you know it's just the way language
is used the the language in course books
is one thing the language spoken in real
life is another thing and um in English
too there's a lot of examples uh one
example is I want to drink some black
coffee in the morning and if you think
about it when you hear it it's totally
normal but if you think about it black
the last part of the word black merges
with call so black coffee nobody would
talk like hey I would like to have some
black coffee in the morning right
so okay so we talked about some of the
reasons why the language spoken by
native speakers is in real life
situations is difficult now let's talk
about how how can we actually understand
these native speakers finally and this
is what we're going to talk about next
so you've developed a very cool language
learning app to solve the problem of
improving one's listening comprehension
how did you come up with the idea well
you remember the incident I mentioned
earlier at the restaurant how could I
forget
okay it was at that time that I realized
I had to do something about my listening
comprehension
so I started watching movies and Series
in Spanish with English subtitles at the
time because I could hardly understand
the Spanish dialogue it's amazing what
you can do nowadays right you can watch
any TV series TV show movie in one
language and then you can watch it also
with subtitles in a wide range of
languages right so this is fantastic for
language learning right that's true uh
but then again movies and series are not
made specifically for the purpose of
language learning so you always run to
the problem that you have to look up
words or figure out the structure of
this sentence or the grammar and in my
case I thought why don't I just write
down the dialogue and see how much of it
I can grasp so I just recorded a scene
on my phone I played it back and then I
just wrote down what I could understand
of it and then after a while I realized
wow I can understand more and more bingo
so this sounds very interesting yeah it
is you want to give it a try of course
okay let's do it
so Luca I prepared a few audio Snippets
for you in several languages and all you
need to do is listen and then type word
for word what you hear and then we'll
check the master transcript and see how
many mistakes he made it's fine but what
if I do not make any mistake then I will
take you out to dinner tonight as your
reward okay sounds good okay let's go
let's get started
so here we are episode one Lucas
listening challenge German let me listen
to the entire episode which is just 13
seconds and then I will go to transcribe
sentence mode and listen to every
sentence and try to figure out whether I
can actually transcribe it well let's
get started
okay so transcribe sentence and let's
see what happens
you can't
okay it gave me a mistake and it says
so you have the the mistake here is the
fact that I did not write a e s entirely
the pronoun uh I think it's no big deal
I think the obstacle still take me to
dinner tonight hopefully and uh let's
move on to the next sentence Oh I want
to just um emphasize the fact that here
if you click on the info button you can
get the translation in English
means I can't believe it let's move on
to uh sentence two Austin
thus then
okay got that right let's move on to
sentence number three
minutes felt
Dyna Mena let me see here Su vex vexilla
um actually it's
dear felt and if you click on the info
this means how easy it is for you to
change men so instead I just wrote
felized
which is actually a little bit weird
means maybe you know so that's not
exactly uh the sentence I I heard it not
very correctly let's move on to sentence
number four
X
uh let me listen to this again because
let's see
almost almost correct I got everything
right except X so the reason why this
happened is because in German you have
to capitalize all nouns and X my
ex-boyfriend so you told me that I have
to forget my about my ex-boyfriend as
soon as possible in this case X is just
a noun so that was a mistake in written
German
and let's listen to the last sentence
let me see here a rat
shlack
okay here I made a mistake because I
heard
schlag but uh actually it's not written
with a d actually means something else
that's what children do for fun okay so
I just uh you know the words actually
sound exactly the same but uh they're
written in a slightly different way
another idiosyncrasy of the beautiful
German language
okay guys so I'm here
um ready to face Lucas listening
challenge French let me do the same
thing that I did before I'm going to
listen to the entire episode 11 seconds
and then I'm gonna move to transcribe
sentence mode
I love the French language
so transcribe sentence let's listen to
The First One
let's see oh there's a mistake there and
it says
so this is interesting because in French
actually the written language is quite
different from the spoken language they
actually say te pavunu but you have to
write when you transcribe to Nipa Junior
let's move on which which means you
haven't come by car more or less let's
move on to sentence number two
foreign
[Music]
which means my car it's colloquialism
again let's see men
right you have to take me to dinner
so let's move on to uh to sentence
number three
sit
got it right
[Music]
and then
thank you wait let me listen to this
again
I forgot the e at the end you know in
French you have vunu which means a Mech
a guy who says I have come uh but in you
know if a girl says I have come
somewhere uh it's the same but there's
an E when you write and I got that wrong
yups is definitely not take me to dinner
too many mistakes so let's move on to
the next sentence
let me see here
okay that's exactly the same mistake
um they actually say oh she actually
says
there was no Metro but in the written
language you have to say there's a
double negation no before the verb and
then I didn't write it so again
um I think yups it's not taking me to
dinner but I think I kind of survived
here I am Lucas listening challenge
Spanish Let's make that happen let me
listen to the episode and then let's
move on to transcribe sentence mode as
usual
um
[Music]
okay this sounds familiar should be at
the beginning the start of the first
episode of La Casa de papel which is a
very uh famous Series in Spanish I think
some of you have watched it so let me
listen to the first sentence let's see
what happens
okay this should be me
Tokyo that should be fine okay I got
that right let's listen to the second
one
here we can use directly uh the accented
syllables SI
let's see
it's good so this means here by clicking
on the info but when the story began I
wasn't called that or that wasn't my
name
yo
no actually this is a mistake
doesn't mean much in Spanish it's
actually esta era that was me instead is
actually he or she will be so uh he she
will be me it doesn't make any sense if
you think about it I should have thought
about it a little bit more this is a
mistake I should have paid a little bit
more attention to actually the stress
estara versus esta erayo but again
connected speech is tricky so sentence
number four that's the last one
okay it gave me the right uh answer it
says it's right although truth be told
there's a comma that I forgot because
she says
she doesn't say yes
but again there's just a comma missing
and lingo field was very forgiving and
maybe yops is gonna be very forgiving as
well and take me to dinner
so Luca how did you like it I I loved it
I I think it was great
um I think it was very interesting to
see how your brain sometimes tricks you
into thinking that you actually know a
sentence a word or a phrase but then you
check it and you realize oh that was not
as I expected but by doing that by
checking you actually learn quite a lot
and it takes also a lot of focus and I
think it has the two main components of
successful and efficient language
learning which are enjoyment on the one
side and a challenge because it is a
challenging exercise but I think any
sort of a growth entails a little bit of
discomfort plus it also helps you not
only to improve your listening
comprehension skills but also you
comment of grammar and your spelling
right so you get the best of both worlds
right the best of all worlds spoken
language and a written language exactly
so guys that's it if you want to know
more about how the app works please
check in the description box below this
video and also the pin comment within
the comment section and I think this is
it right this is it so this is it guys
as always happy language learning and
bye for me bye for me
[Music]
foreign
okay so do I get to choose the
restaurant sure as long as it's my
stomach is wrong like right now so we
should actually go
foreign